今日は遊び雪ようです最近の有名なユーチューバーほとんどみんな東京に住んでいる
みたいなんだが俺は夢だに静岡に住んでいる
そしてユーチューバーの友達が
こういないなぜですね基本なんでも酷ねぇで解決しちゃうね人ん家に行くことがほぼ
ないんですよってかもうないひとつに行くことがないんでたまには誰かん家に行きたい
なと思いまして今日は私の後輩ユーチューバーにあたる立面の以前にちょっと行って
みようと思いますバレーずにね会い時は何をするかと言いますとあいつ今 by it
に入ってるんです bye
人に入ってるんで枚頭のいいな誰もいないいるのはあいつの家族だけでそんな家族の
なか僕立面の父ちゃんの連絡先を知ってるんで
縦目の統治に連絡をしてあの夜中に家に行っていいですかっていうを許しをもらいます
あのやっぱさん夜中に行くのは大変失礼なことだと思ってちゃんの確認を取って
コーナー申し上げなそうに行ってみますか多分バイト
終わったらいつ帰ってくるんでターゲットの部屋で治すがんばれずに良いでいるか継承
してみようと思いますただ行くだけじゃつまんないですからねぇ
というわけで正しいターゲットの家に何分間隠れているのでしょうか
ねあいつバカだから多分そうと気付かないと思うんですよねあの目標はまあ
1カ月半
彼の家に隠れていうかなと思います良ければん山この時に動画の講師が1ヶ月半行われ
ないかも知れません申し訳ございますでは早速隠れていきましょう
バイトから帰ってくるので付けようと思います
俺のこと好きなが2ヶ瀬までが進んだ
俺もあったことあるんだけどね
ん
ええええええ
カフェ
[音楽]
dj
しゃべれもしてみるただしうん
うーん
[音楽]
me
ん
うん
[音楽]
ん
うん
サービスあ
[音楽]
ええええええ
ん
ああああああ
[音楽]
ん
同校に各で8日
あっ振る舞った後かなると思うよね思って隠れるスペースが多分
後ふとのれた国家ワークスファルとしたらこのスイッチ間な気がします貼っつけました
か図書としちゃう
ありません
[音楽]
ええええええ
[拍手]
なった
ん
います
reg を受けません
ています
おっん
[音楽]
もしもし漬け今どこ行って私はを浴びてる
を振っ ok ブービーからさーああため部屋で待っててああ
強いうん
横領これなんかフライドやらすぐ出れないからさ
あーを注げば起こりません灰色かですよねジャガー ie
入っちゃいまーす
ん
[音楽]
好きだった
ん
い
[音楽]
がーーーーーーーイ w
てす
[音楽]
ああああああああああっ
me
teame
ana あああっ
同湖はっはっはえっ
何してそうえっこれ自供
えっ
ています
というわけでこのハエの家に侵入すると約17分でバレることがわかりました
ありがとうございます
指方やをもっすべくワイフ本当に以後まで10分